you know what's interesting is you know
i talked to all my friends that live in
texas they live in utah and they live in
montana and
they live in arizona and you know
there's just been a rash of people
leaving california
businesses leaving california my friends
a bunch of my friends have left
california
and
i love california
california is freaking awesome it is
california has the pacific ocean it has
the mountains it has the desert it has
the redwood trees it has yosemite it is
a magnificent place it is absolutely
magnificent
and
yeah it is in a very
precarious situation right now that i
don't think it can i don't think it i
don't think it can continue to go this
way
i mean you've seen the news you've seen
the the
the
homeless situations yeah you see the
the trains that were getting attacked
and
you know
robbed from entire freight trains
um i don't know what's gonna happen man
i don't know what's going to happen in
california i
i love california california is an
iconic place
and there's and the other thing you got
to remember about california is
california is not san francisco and los
angeles that's not california right
that's a small part of california
california is the imperial valley
right california is the agriculture that
is the vast majority of this state
and hard-working americans that are out
there busting their ass to make things
work and at the same time paying an
incredible amount of taxes and having
the regulatory environment that's
that's
hostile
to business legitimately hostile right
so
with all these things as they continue
to add up
um
i can't predict the future i certainly
hope i don't have to get into politics i
i really just don't know if i have the
stomach for it
um
i don't want to do it man i i know it's
like just the biggest cop out that i can
throw back at you at this point and and
you and the rest of the guys that are
out there trying to do it for the right
reasons
is awesome
um
man i don't i don't want to get into
that business i don't want to get into
that world and
you know i when people ask me about
politics i always tell them that you
know i'm not i don't want to do it
unless things get really bad people hit
me up all the time is it bad enough yet
is it bad enough yet is it bad enough
yet
i don't know where that line is for me
um
i feel a dumb and dumber moment coming
on right now where i just want to say
so you're saying there's a chance
there's a chance okay
one in a million
awesome
uh
don't like it no i hear you i hear it's
an it's nasty man it's a nasty world and
it's a god dude and i i'm barely even
scratching the surface of it but even
now like
i i don't really like the world i don't
like the self-promotion of going around
campaigning and telling people why
you're so great and why they should vote
for you i don't like that part of it i
don't like the nastiness of
you know people lying
lying about you and trying to smear you
in you know
every single way possible and if they
can't come up with anything good they'll
just make it up i don't like that part
of it
i don't like exposing my family you know
to this stuff as well i just want my
kids to grow up
kind of like a normal life and
but i'll tell you what man it's like if
enough of us don't do it
we're done yeah that's the way i see it
man and i wish i was more optimistic but
i watched like just like on a uh you
know a dope sheet as a sniper man i
watch trajectories i watch where this
country started and where we're at now
man and it's
i mean covet if if that doesn't wake
people up
you know to uh
you know the fact that
often most often governments aren't
typically interested
in
letting the power rest with the people
i don't know what's gonna wake people up
but
it it's it's getting bad and we need to
we need some sled dogs to put their uh
and maybe a couple leaders
to put their uh their shoulder to the
wheel but just saying